[THEME MUSIC]
[COFFEE POURING]
What's up, everyone?
This is "Disney+ Deets,"
where we break down everything
you need to know about
your favorite Disney+
movies and series.
I'm Kenneth--
MARCELLUS: And I'm Marcellus,
and not to toot our own horns,
but we're pretty
much the biggest
Disney+ fans out there.
No, let's do it!
Toot toot!
Beep beep!
That's right!
Let's get into it.
[THEME MUSIC]
KENNETH: Today, we're telling
you what you need to know,
and what you maybe
didn't know about Marvel
Studios' "Black Panther."
Like so many of
you out there, Marcellus and
I have been really
devastated over the loss
of the great Chadwick Boseman.
Who, of course, brought
the Black Panther to life.
MARCELLUS: Yes,
Ken, his performance
was everything to me.
He embodied the
character so well.
It was really a joy to watch.
KENNETH: When Chadwick Boseman
first appears on screen,
it's literally the embodiment
of Wakanda walking before you.
MARCELLUS: Yeah.
KENNETH: I remember
sitting in the theater
and I just got chills.
Of course, I was
in my African garb,
and I just wanted to
rise up in the theater.
But, I want to say
this, Chadwick Boseman
will always be missed,
and we're so happy that we
have this piece of him--
MARCELLUS: Yeah.
KENNETH: --on film forever.
MARCELLUS: I agree, Ken.
And we want to pay
tribute to Chadwick
and celebrate all the
talent and hard work
that went into the making
of this great film.
KENNETH: Yes, sir.
So give us some history of
the characters, Marcellus.
MARCELLUS: The Black Panther
character first appeared over
50 years ago, in "Fantastic
Four" Volume 1, Issue 52,
published in 1966.
His first appearance in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe,
however, was in 2016's
"Captain America: Civil War."
KENNETH: Chadwick Boseman
is perfect for this.
Nate Moore, the film's
executive producer,
said that Chadwick read
all the comic books,
he came to him with
questions, and he had
his own ideas about Wakanda.
He was not taking
anything for granted
and was fully
invested in the role.
MARCELLUS: You really feel that.
This film is directed and
co-written by Ryan Coogler,
and, Ken, I'm obsessed.
I really admire him.
KENNETH: This is
his third feature
film with Michael B.
Jordan, who portrays
Killmonger in the film.
Jordan has said that Black
Panther was a character he'd
look up to his entire life.
Ugh, the Dora Milaje.
MARCELLUS: Oh.
KENNETH: They are Wakanda's
all-female special force
unit, led by Danai Gurira,
also known as Okoye.
MARCELLUS: Shout
out to you, Danai.
[APPLAUSE]
KENNETH: Girl power.
I'm not mad about it.
MARCELLUS: To fill the ranks
of this elite security force,
the filmmakers and stunt team
met with hundreds of women,
including film and
television stunt players,
track and field athletes,
dancers, and MMA fighters.
KENNETH: Mm-hmm.
MARCELLUS: Listen, they were
not to be toyed with at all.
KENNETH: The main cast
spent three months training
for the demanding
action in the film,
mostly doing their own stunts.
MARCELLUS: Yes, you
can really tell.
KENNETH: The cast and
stunt team also practiced
with African drums so
their movements would have
a musical quality that's found
in many African-based martial
arts styles.
It's just the
rhythm and the soul.
KENNETH: [LAUGHS] Yes.
Winston Duke plays
M'Baku, and this was
his first major motion picture.
[M'BAKU CHANT]
KENNETH: Exactly, we were
all sitting in a theater,
but after that chant
everyone wanted
to stand up to attention.
[MIMICS M'BAKU CHANT]
MARCELLUS: Yeah.
KENNETH: He was great.
Oh my God, look at Wakanda!
MARCELLUS: Yes.
KENNETH: Ryan Coogler
brought on production
designer, Hannah Beachler,
to bring the world of Wakanda
to life.
So Wakanda's main
resource is the metal
known as Vibranium, right?
MARCELLUS: Right.
KENNETH: Biechler wanted
to incorporate that
into her designs as
much as possible.
MARCELLUS: Yeah.
KENNETH: She even went to
mining and metallurgy experts
to determine what the different
phases of Vibranium could be.
MARCELLUS: Ken, you lost me.
KENNETH: I almost lost myself.
[LAUGHTER]
MARCELLUS: Ken, look
at this, the Warrior
Falls set is one of the most
impressive in the film.
KENNETH: Yeah.
MARCELLUS: It was inspired
by the real life Oribi Gorge
in South Africa.
KENNETH: The massive set, built
on a back lot north of Atlanta,
clocked in at what--
120 by 75 feet?
MARCELLUS: What?
KENNETH: With practical
cliff faces 30 feet tall.
Now, instead of actual rock,
MARCELLUS: Mm-hmm.
KENNETH: Over 25,000 cubic feet
of foam was used for the set.
The bottom of the challenge pool
was padded for the stunt team.
MARCELLUS: OK.
KENNETH: But was painted
to look like rock.
The filmmaking team also
engineered a fully functional
flowing waterfall and pool
at the ledge of the cliff
with six pumps feeding
over 125,000 gallons of
temperature-controlled water.
MARCELLUS: Oh, wow.
KENNETH: Doing what?
Piping up through the set
at a rate of how much?
I'm glad you asked,
30,000 gallons per minute.
Before doing what?
Recirculating
through the system!
MARCELLUS: Ken, I probably
would try to go swimming.
KENNETH: [LAUGHS]
You would, you would.
MARCELLUS: [LAUGHS]
Just swimming.
Yes, this part right here.
This chase sequence
was filmed on location
in the actual streets
of Busan, South Korea.
KENNETH: I want you
to realize, the way
they driving in this scene--
MARCELLUS: Yeah.
KENNETH: --is how
my mama was driving
trying to get me to school
when we missed the bus.
MARCELLUS: Oh, I understand.
KENNETH: [LAUGHS]
MARCELLUS: And you know what
I really notice in this?
Ryan Coogler wanted
the South Korea
action sequence to be seamless.
So he had an editor
on set cutting
footage in real
time, which isn't
usually done during production.
But Coogler felt
it was the best way
to capture all the action,
stunts, and special effects
in the frame, on time.
Wakanda is a modern society
that's deeply in touch
with its history.
KENNETH: Mm-hmm.
MARCELLUS: You can see it
especially in this set.
It's sleek and modern, with
visual effects, enhancements.
KENNETH: Mm-hmm.
MARCELLUS: But then,
under the high-tech glass
floor is an ancient ruin--
KENNETH: I saw that.
MARCELLUS: --on the metal
columns of the room,
you can find script written in
5th century Nigerian language.
KENNETH: That's that
detail, that's that detail.
MARCELLUS: Mm-hmm.
KENNETH: Now look at
these amazing costumes.
Costume designer Ruth
Carter searched the world
from Ghana to Los Angeles--
MARCELLUS: OK.
KENNETH: --for textiles and
accessories used to create
the 700 costumes in the film.
Coogler and his team
established a strict color
theme-ing for the film.
For example, blue represented
danger or trouble.
MARCELLUS: Mmm.
KENNETH: So blue was reserved
for the border tribe,
who act as a policing force.
MARCELLUS: Mm-hmm.
KENNETH: And Killmonger's
character also wore blue.
No one else is in
any kind of blue.
MARCELLUS: That's right.
KENNETH: And the
river tribe right
here, which is Nakia's tribe--
MARCELLUS: Uh-huh.
KENNETH: --wears green.
Lupita Nyong'o, who plays Nakia,
wears many different shades
of green in her costumes.
Carter said greens
mix well together
because it's like nature.
Now, I want to talk about
one of my favorite things
about "Black Panther."
MARCELLUS: What's that?
KENNETH: Well with the cast
from all over the world, Coogler
brought in a dialect
coach to ensure
there was continuity amongst
all of them. I love that.
That's thinking
through every detail.
MARCELLUS: Mm-hm ]m.
KENNETH: Now, because actor
John Kani's native language
is Xhosa, one of the official
languages of South Africa,
it became the official
language of Wakanda.
MARCELLUS: Yeah.
I really love the celebration
of African culture
in this movie, Ken.
KENNETH: I'm always going to
have memories of my family
and friends dressing up
in our African attire
to go and see the
premiere of this film.
There was such a sense of
community in the theater,
and amongst all of us.
And to see these
characters who were
in the comic books come to life
right before our very eyes,
was powerful.
MARCELLUS: Yeah.
KENNETH: Representation matters.
MARCELLUS: It does.
It really does.
And you know what?
That's our show for today.
Marvel Studios'
"Black Panther" is
now streaming on Disney+.
KENNETH: Wakanda forever.
Chadwick Boseman forever.
MARCELLUS: Forever, indeed.
KENNETH: Until next time,
Kenneth and Marcellus, out.